all right uh so going to pick up with
second tutorial
um where we'll be talking a bit more
about neural network optimization um
the last one we were talking a bit more
about generalization in this one we're
just mainly going to be talking about
optimization
so we were looking at uh
you know various conditions under which
we could guarantee that the empirical
risk is going to be close to the
population risk for the erm
um and so
the natural question is
can we actually find this erm or what
you know what does that actually involve
when we're looking at neural network
extreme by gradient descent
okay so to start i just want to do a
refresher on convexity
uh so we'll call a differentiable
function g is convex if
uh we this inequality is satisfied and
the way to think about it is that the
first order taylor approximation of the
of the function the the function value
is always above its first order taylor
approximation of
of itself right so on the left we have a
convex function
and the middle on the right we have
non-convex functions right
and you know if we have if we have two
derivatives then it's convex if the
hessian is semi-positive definite
and the classical algorithm that we'll
be looking at is gradient descent
with the fixed learning rate
and so gradient descent is this rule
that says you always go down until you
hit a flat part and then you stop and so
the goal is to try to get as far down
the mountain as you can and
you know if you have a convex landscape
then we'll we'll show how you're able to
get to the lowest part of the landscape
but if you have non-convex landscapes
right if you just follow the rule of go
down until you hit flat part you go from
here down then you stop right there's no
way to get to this global uh
minimum because you get stuck in in this
slot part in a different part of the
landscape
okay so i'm just going to quickly go
through a simple proof of that that
gradient descent finds a minima of
smooth convex functions
um so we'll use smooth by smooth i'll
just mean that we have the lip shits
bound so the gradient is bound the norm
of the gradient is bounded by this l1
um
and we'll take a step size that's small
this is just for simplicity for the
simplest proof possible
um
right so the way we'll we'll we'll show
that gradient descent finds minima is is
to look at the difference between
uh the distance between wt the weights
found at time t and some fixed predictor
w star which achieves the global minimum
value
right and if you write out
if you just expand the square what
you're left with is this cross term
which is you get two times the cross
term which is the gradient inner product
wt minus w star minus eta squared norm
gradient squared
okay if we use the definition of
convexity that allows for us to bound
from below
this inner product term by the gap
between the function value at time t and
the optimal function value g of w star
now if we use this smoothness term
we can bound the gradient norm by l one
right so we're left with a null one
squared
and then if we use uh we're using a
small step size then we can make this
eta l1 squared smaller than epsilon
right so from here we just kind of argue
inductively which is to say let's
suppose that at time t
the function value at time t is bigger
than the minimum value achieved
plus some epsilon
right so we want to say that eventually
this condition is not satisfied but
let's just consider every iteration
until this while this thing is satisfied
okay so if g of wt is bigger than g of w
star plus epsilon
what we're left with here is two eta
times epsilon minus epsilon over two
right so we just get two eta times
epsilon over two which is just eta
epsilon
and if we rearrange this inequality then
what we're left with is every iteration
where this inequality is satisfied where
the function value is at least epsilon
bigger than the global minimum value
the distance
at time t plus 1 to the to w star
is eta epsilon smaller than the distance
it was at time t
okay
and this is true for every time t where
we have a function value that's bigger
than the global optimum value plus
epsilon
right and this is always a non-negative
quantity right it's a norm squared
and so this can only decrease for a
finite number of iterations right we can
only decrease have an upper bound that
is positive for a finite number of
iterations because we can just continue
to iterate this argument to say it's
going to be smaller and smaller and
smaller and so eventually we must reach
some points that g the function value
found by gradient descent is within
epsilon of the global optimum value
right so
very very simple very clean proof
if we have convexity and if we have
smoothness
and so you know
neural network optimization problems are
not convex
so this kind of approach that we're
taking before is not necessarily going
to it will
absolutely not yield something
immediately for neural network
optimization problems
uh and in general when you have a
non-convex function the best thing that
you can hope for is to get
to find a stationary point right the
gradient descent algorithm terminates
when we find a flat point which is when
the gradient is zero
and you know in some settings we might
be able to hope that if the gradient is
equal to zero we achieve something close
to global optimum value
right so that's not the case here but if
you say you randomly initialize you know
99 of places that you start at
the globe the value that you reach will
be close to the global optimum in that
in that kind of landscape
but of course if you randomly initialize
over here uh you're not going to come
close to finding the global optimum most
of the time
right so
what we'll next talk about is trying to
characterize types of pro these types of
problems where
stationary points points where the
gradient norm is small says something
about the global
about the global optimum value and
achieving that with gradient descent
okay so what we'll
in particular look at is is this polygon
polyacryl yesterwhich inequality
or pl
and
how we define this is let's just
consider a differentiable function
that's non-negative
and we say that it achieves some minimum
value opt and we say that it satisfies
the pl inequality if there are some
positive constants alpha and mu such
that for all w the gradient norm to this
alpha
can be bounded from below by some
constant times the gap
between the function value itself and
the optimal value
so the thing to note is that there are
non-convex functions that satisfy this
inequality right so
that's good but the the better thing is
that if this inequality is satisfied
and we can find stationary points right
where this gradient norm is going to go
to zero
then that means that this term must also
go to zero right so we have positive
constant here that means that g of w
minus opt must go to zero so g of w is
going to be close to the opposite value
so gradient descent's going to find
something close to the optimal value uh
for this problem
right and and this is something that uh
you know this type of inequality is
something that's appeared in a lot of
the neural network optimization works
and seems to be a pretty unifying
thing
so we're going to talk a bit more about
how what how to interpret this
inequality for neural network training
and how do we actually go about
establishing it
okay
um
so we'll consider uh in the remainder
just classification tasks where the
labels are going to be binary plus minus
one
uh and we'll just be talking about
training with the exponential loss and
maybe we'll get into what happens with
uh other convex decreasing loss
functions afterwards
right so uh you know the exponential
loss is this one in the red it's
something that's an upper bound for the
zero one loss
uh you know and so since the zero it's
an upper bound for the zero one loss if
we're able to minimize the exponential
loss we're able to minimize the zero one
loss
and we'll look at uh we're gonna just be
taking the loss function which is just
going to be the margin right so this is
what we'll call the margin is the label
times the
uh
the network output with parameters w
and the exponential loss we have
exponential minus margin
and we'll be looking at training
problems where we have n iid samples and
we're looking at the empirical risk
for those iid samples
all right so how do we
go about establishing this pl inequality
all right so just a reminder the pl
inequality holds if we can show that
there are some constants alpha and c
such this gradient norm for the
empirical risk to the alpha can be
bounded from below by a constant times l
hat of w right so this is assuming opt
is zero for instance
right and and so one kind of
obvious way to start is to consider
alpha equals one
and then use the variational definition
of the norm right so
uh then the l2 norm can be written as
the maximum of inner products with a
given fixed vector that has uh most unit
norm so in particular a lower bound for
this gradient norm is given by the inner
product with some
any vector v that has unit norm
and if you just write out what this
gradient looks like
we're left with is the average of minus
l primes
right of the the margin so y i times f
of x i wt
and then this remaining term which is y
i times the inner product of the
gradient
with this vector v
okay
now we can do some simplification we're
looking at the exponential loss the
exponential law satisfies that minus l
prime is equal to l
so that allows for us to change this
minus l prime to l here
and then we just bring down this other
term here
i'm just gonna pause for a second
because this this is the quantity that
we're gonna be spending the next half
hour really thinking about and trying to
intuitively understand
what it is and how we can show get some
type of control over it and what that
means for pl inequalities
right so i'll refer to this as kind of
gradient margin
okay we call it a gradient margin
because you can think of it as a
function
the function
is the gradient inner product with a
fixed vector right as opposed to the
actual margin is y i times f of x i wt
but it's helpful to think of just this
inner product term as a function
itself right and
and
you know in order to show a pl
inequality what its advice is to show is
that this is always bigger than some
absolute constant
for all i
okay so because if that is true you know
this is some constant
then we can bound this from below from
by a constant times the loss
you know the average of the losses and
that's exactly what this pl inequality
is
um so again
our task then
what this shows is that the task is that
we want to be able to construct some
vector v
such that this quantity
is positive for all i if we can do that
then we have a pl inequality if we have
a pl inequality it means that whenever
we find stationary points here the loss
is going to be small
so clear on clear on the setup
okay
so i just want to kind of describe what
this thing is in words and and how we
might you know go about understanding it
um
right so
we're basically trying to take
some linear function of the gradient
features
so v is you know you think of v dot
something is a linear this is a linear
function
but it's a linear function of the
gradient features
right so is there some type of linear
combination of the features that are
given by the gradient of the network at
time t
that is able to classify examples well
if this is true then we have a pl
inequality and we're able to show uh you
know optimization we can have uh get to
zero risk
but the trouble is that
you know this gradient of the network at
time t
is kind of hard to get a gra
grapple of right because
it changes
over time in you know not obvious ways
right it
incorporates data dependent information
you don't have
some very you know
only in some special situations it's
super easy to understand
what it actually looks like at all times
t
right but something that might be a
little bit easier to understand is the
gradient of the network at
initialization
right so if you look at the gradient of
the network at initialization
you have some random matrix w0
and the hope is that you know you might
be able to utilize some type of
properties of gaussian matrices or
whatever type of random initialization
randomization initialization you have
to be able to understand if there are
linear combinations of these gradients
that can allow for good classification
right
and then you know you could argue that
if you're at least staying close to the
initialization
then these gradients at time t might
look close to the gradients at time zero
and so if you have some type of control
over the gradients at time zero that
says that there are good features at you
know time zero then maybe you could say
something in some type of neighborhood
around initialization where such a thing
is still true
right and and this seems like a perhaps
more tractable path forward to being
able to understand what's going on
is to look at what's happening at
initialization and then argue about
staying close to initialization
and that's what we'll be talking about
next is this idea of looking at what's
happening at random initialization to
talk about
uh neural network optimization
trajectories near its random
initialization
okay
so i'm just going to do some
i'm going to focus on this two layer
network setup and and talk about this
this idea of the neural tangent kernel
because that's really what's going on
here when we're looking at what's going
on at random initialization
um so we'll look at two layer networks
with some activation phi where the
second layer is fixed and we're just
going to be looking at training the
first layer
because this is still a non-convex
problem
you can still learn useful features of
the data in this setting
we'll think about the second layer
weights being plus minus 1 over root m
where m is the number of neurons
okay so
we can write the gradient formula as a
uh product uh between a diagonal matrix
uh that has the derivatives of the uh of
the network at for each neuron
uh a is this vector of of uh second
layer uh that matrix uh weights and x is
the input
all right and again we'll just be
considering what happens when you have
iid
standard gaussian entries right and in
this setting then the gradient is random
because it has
this uh diagonal matrix which is random
has phi primes of different wj dot x's
and we're interested in understanding
when we can construct
some uh you know vector v or you know
some matrix v
such that this quantity that's this
gradient margin
with the gradient at time zero is
positive
um
and this is going to be the setup that
we're going to be talking about uh for
the next few slides
everyone let me know if you have any
questions uh but this is what we'll be
looking at
okay so
if we just take a look
back here right so this is a
a sum of linear combinations of these
you know vjs
with these feet these linear
you know linear functions of these you
can think of as features
x i times phi prime w j zero dot x i
okay so these are essentially
random features and we're looking at
random combinations of we're looking at
linear combinations of these random
features
so this kind of motivates looking at a
kernel function right because we have
these kind of feature embeddings that
are given by the gradients of the
network
which is you know
it should remind you of the idea of
kernels
so if we look at this kernel function
that looks that takes the gradient of
the network with respect to the weights
and we say that's the kernel function
between a sample x and another sample z
is just the correlation between those
two
what do we get
okay we substitute in the definition of
the gradient here
we use the definition of
inner products between matrices to get a
trace term
right
we use the cyclic property of the trace
to bring this z transpose over here
then we have z transpose x times
something else that's a scalar
so we can take z transpose x out and
then we have this other scalar oh this
should not be a
get rid of that perp there but there
should not be a proof there but this is
a scalar quantity here
if we write out what that that scalar
quantity is it's the average
of these five the products of these five
primes on different x's and z's
okay and then we just rewrite this this
quantity
uh
in a somewhat more suggestive way where
we're looking at
uh the
the pro the inner products between x phi
prime w j zero dot x and z phi prime w j
zero dot z
uh you could do this uh but you'll see
what the problem what what simplifies
when you look at initialization in a
second
right uh
right so when we write it in this way uh
we have each sum in this term
is independent and identically
distributed
and so we have an average of the sum of
independent identically distributed
random variables by the law of large
numbers it converges to its mean
and if we had uh if we're looking at
time t it's not the case that these are
going to be independent and identically
distributed right because these wjts
will depend upon all the other stuff
going on
right and so this
when we take this average what we're
left with is an average over
gaussian random variables right because
these w j zero are sampled from a
standard gaussian
of this quantity that's the inner
product in x y prime at x and z phi
prime at z
right and this this final kernel here is
is what's known as the neural tangent
kernel right so this is the neural
tangent kernel that arises when we're
looking at a two layer network and only
train the first layer
uh there are analogs of this for
many neural network architectures
and you know this is a study a subject
of a lot of work over the past few years
is understanding what are the types of
kernel functions that you get
when you have different neural network
architectures
um so we'll refer to this
this k is the the ntk
this k hat is the kind of empirical ntk
so it's empirical because we have some m
samples or m neurons uh and we have some
randomness there
but when we take this average the
randomness disappears right we're taking
an average over the randomness there and
so we don't actually have a random
quantity on the right-hand side
is there is there some sort of a measure
between
12
is there's is there some sample
complexity measured for estimating this
like the panel that you get with your
training samples versus the limiting
kernel
um
yes i mean you can characterize how many
how many neurons you need to be able to
have but this is in terms of the number
of samples m right m is the number of
neurons
right so so m is uh yeah so we have an m
we have an m neuron network that's like
uh
we're looking at f of
x w is like
some number j equals one to m
aj
phi
w j x
alright so m is the number of neurons in
the network
yeah so it
yeah yeah i mean this is just uh the
strong amount of large numbers or you
can
use independent random variables
um
so this is the mtk
and this
you know
this is so the idea of the ntk is that
we have these uh
these random features that come from
taking the gradient to the network at
initialization
right and and these types of these
random features
uh can be thought of as you know feature
embeddings that can be used to define a
kernel this empirical ntk that k hat
such that when we take this infinite
width limit we're left with some
deterministic quantity which
is the actual mtk
and so this expectation can be we can
write it in terms of an integral
um
you know
this whole idea is that these these x's
and phi prime w dot x this quantity
itself
is a feature that uh you know that we're
interested in in
in that that naturally emerges when we
take this infinite width limit at
initialization
so this kind of motivates uh assumptions
that we can think about for the training
data
in order to try to understand uh neural
network optimization which is that
there exists some uh we can think of
this as like you know this is like an
infinite width network
and so we can think of
there being some type of weights that
depend on these infinite weights that
depend on
w and w is parameterized by rd so it's
infinite
and that we assume that there is some u
that takes parameters from rd and maps
it to other parameters in rd that have
norm at most one and we assume that this
this u is such that
we can classify examples from the
training data well
using an infinite width network with
these
random features x i phi prime of w dot x
that are able to be classified well
using those second layer weights u of w
all right so this is kind of using these
what we call tangent features or the
gradients of these phi primes which are
the terms that appear in red
and we're using these weights uh this
should be a u uh u of w and this uh p of
w dw
so this is kind of an infinite
dimensional
uh
version of trying to be having this
having this ntk with infinite weights
that is able to classify the data well
and so the idea is that if this type of
thing holds then we might expect that
a neural network that is near its
initialization and that's sufficiently
wide can also
classify things well
instead of being bounded by one they
were mounted by constant b
um
does anything break uh
yeah and not well the complexity uh
would change i'm not super familiar with
what what actual
so in some sense this this uh
if you allow for this to be unbounded
then you can approximate like any
continuous function basically so this is
putting a restriction on how
uh this is a kind of smaller subclass
than all continuous functions
but it is still something that's uh
somewhat large
if matus is here you can probably
comment a bit better on the precise
approximation power of this uh
would you say correct
uh yeah we'll get we'll get to this uh
yeah it's uh no i guess this is the
thing but at least it gives us some
insight into how things might work in
some stage of training for some neural
network widths
okay
so yes we'll be working with this
assumption um
and as i was mentioning before uh you
know this is the infinite width limit
and so we can think about what happens
when we have finite with networks and
try to characterize how how large the
width needs to be in order for
for this approximation to be good
right um
as i mentioned before you know these are
adding iid
m iid samples
uh where these wj0s are iid right and so
by the law of large numbers we know that
uh when m is sufficiently large this
will
be true right and you could
easily use hoffman's inequality or
otherwise to characterize how how large
exactly m needs to be
but i just want to
kind of bring this this type of
assumption back into what i was
discussing before about these gradient
margin quantities and how we want to
construct linear features of the
gradient or the linear functions of the
gradient
in order to classify well
right so
if we let
these vjs remember vjs are the columns
of the v transpose matrix so the rows of
the v matrix
if we let these vjs be equal to aj which
is the second layer weight and then this
u applied to w j0
why are we doing this is because
we have this u of w here right which
suggests that we're taking u of w
as the features as a linear function
that we're going to be using of the
gradient features
so that suggests using that u of w j0
for the jth neuron
to do classification
and if you just substitute in that
quantity there
what you see is that we have this
average of j from one to m
uh these y i's times the gradient of the
jth neuron
times these u of w j zero
and this is precisely what this quantity
is here
and so when m is large
we can expect that this thing is going
to be at least order of
gamma so so what is this saying right
what this is saying is that we've we've
assumed that there is some infinite with
network that can classify the the
training data at some example gamma
and we know that an initialization this
uh when m is sufficiently large
uh we can all we can also classify the
data well using uh these uh
xi using these u of w j zero
and so we can just construct this matrix
this matrix v such that this gradient
margin quantity is going to also be at
least order gamma
oh
because it's not going to be true if for
instance the dimension is much more the
number of training samples is much
larger than the dimension
it could be in some settings so so for
instance linearly separable data
satisfies this uh this is one this is
one
instance think
low degree polynomials should be able to
satisfy this as well
low degree polynomial threshold
functions but
uh i don't know materials what is that
what is the trade-off between the number
of samples and the dimension which will
make this true
so so here's the question so here uh you
can also think about just the
distribution itself satisfying this
right you can think about x's and y's
for the distribution satisfying that and
then it just becomes a question of what
is the approximation power of this
rather than like a trade-off between the
number of samples of dimension
i think that's a
and so in that setting it's it's easier
to get some type of grasp because then
this is an approximation theoretical
question
what is actually representative from
this okay
so
uw theories independently later
independent with other
variables
so so u and w there's there's no there's
nothing about
so u is a deterministic thing here right
i mean i guess it could depend on the
x's and y's but the fact is that it's uh
as norm the output of r is one
we're not using the fact that u and w js
are
third question
from this market
if you have a lower bound on the impuri
the singular value of the empirical ntk
then that should give you
something right
i guess you would use the other x
the z's and the or the x's and the five
primes or what would
[Music]
uh
yeah yeah i'm not
i'm not sure but uh maybe i can get back
to you on that one
so i want to get into something about
how we actually use this to establish
this uh pl yeah yep
one very nice thing about this quantity
is it actually does depend on labels
and so there are many cases where this
is much better than what you get by
using the the minimum singer value of
the of the gram matrix
and one comment i want to make is that
a standard check for this quantity is
that for the two sparse variant problem
this margin is one over d
and if you translate that into greater
percent guarantee it gets the optimal
sample complexity over all kernel
methods so at least for sparse
polynomials this abstraction means
nothing so it's uh yeah and i don't know
how to do that if we use a singular
value
um
yeah so just to recap where we're at
with uh where this assumption gets us
right what it gives us is that this
gradient margin can be bigger than some
gamma over two whenever it's larger
right and how does this give us the pl
inequality uh the pl inequality
as we had before can be bounded from
below by this average of the ls the
losses times this gradient margin right
and so the important thing here is that
this gradient is at time t
uh in this matrix v the heuristics
and so if we use this
mtk approximation that's
the distance between wt and w0 to small
then we can
have at a high level some approximation
between the gradients at time t being
close to the gradients at time zero
okay and if we have that
then we can just substitute in this
lower bound for the gradients at
time zero and get a gamma over two
factor in front and this just results in
a pl inequality where the constant c is
gamma over two
and so in this setting what this means
is that we if we have this type of
assumption uh about this infinite with
network being able to classify the
training data well
then we can have at stationary points
we'll have small empirical risk under
the exponential loss
okay um so then i wanted to talk a bit
about you know what is what are we
losing and how complete is this uh ntk
approximation
and and what is it what is it is it
actually you know an accurate depiction
of reality for neural networks that we
see in practice
right so the approximation relies upon
the fact that he says i've presented it
that the gradients of the network at
time t
are close to the gradients of the
network at initialization
if we're making that approximation it
means that we're not the weights wt that
we're considering
do not actually
incorporate data dependent information
in any way right we're just saying that
what's going on is close to what's
happening at initialization i just wait
one second
and so
we can you know think about uh you know
so this is this is something that
obviously doesn't seem true in practice
at a higher level right the data like
clearly the data affects the weights
that are learned by gradient descent
that are you know in neural networks
that are in the neural networks that are
used in practice but we can also see
this uh in terms of uh the sample
complexity that results for for you know
actual neural networks that are trained
uh beyond this kind of ntk regime versus
what's happening with these empirical
ntks and these infinite with limits
okay so this is some work uh
by nikhil vias and and co-authors that
looks at a kind of variant of the c far
10
problem
and
what you can see is that you know the
what they're looking at here is is how
the test error decreases as uh you
increase the sample size
right and so
what you observe is that the neural
networks that are not in this kind of
ndk regime have a much better sample
complexity than these
ntks that are used uh either the
empirical version or the infinite one
[Music]
um yes so the loss itself
so the loss itself is is a the product
of y times f
it's a so when you take the gradients
you get an l term out and you get the
gradients
so this is just a classification problem
this is like the default way that
binary classification problems are done
so if you do the logistic loss
with this type of parameterization this
corresponds to
how minor classification problems are
kind of like tensorflow so all of these
durations might not be valid
there are variants of this for verbals
as well
it's just it just looks it looks it's
more complicated than
there will still be multiplications of y
times uh the label that you have but it
depends on how you do it like you either
have one hot labels or you can
there's many different ways but it's
it's easy to translate this to multiple
questions
do you know how they bought these plots
for compute across the all of these
models
yes so so this is on this uh
i believe it is normalized for compute
in each of them uh but the precise
details
here and you can
discuss it more clearly than these but
uh
this is like a relatively fair
comparison uh where they're using not
see far 10 or hsp part 10 doesn't have
that many it uses like a degenerative
model that can have things you know
for safety participants and to evaluate
it
um
but this is
it
explain why is green line and the red
line are so far apart
yes this i i'm not sure what the
i think it's it's not clear to me what
what is what is responsible for the
infinite mdk being better
you know when the empirical is large
enough the lines become closer and
closer but uh this gap i'm not sure is
has been explained that uh maybe someone
in the audience
uh
yeah so
i sorry so the point of this thought is
just to show that neural networks have
better sample complexity than the ntks
of either kind
so
as long as we know that this green one
is going to look close to the infinite
ones as the width goes straight so we
can
yes this is average over different uh
random dislocations uh and it's a it's
some fixed width i'm not sure
i think the the takeaway from from this
is just that
the
neural networks that are not in the mdk
regime are able to utilize data
dependent information in a way that
produces sample complexity and then if
you don't do that then you can you
suffer
rather than like smooth spikes
yeah so
yeah so i mean in some sense so the ntk
is a kernel and so the kernel can suffer
from you know this not being able to
localize to the data and that could be
viewed as a reason why this is happening
yeah
it's like super smooth then they would
probably be somewhat similar
so you need to indicate a gene like is
it's yeah i mean it's a
it's a good question uh i think it
depends upon how you do training um like
if you take a really large step size and
you have a small initialization variance
this approximation will be broken after
one step
uh if you use a smaller step size and
have a larger initialization variance
this could hold for a larger time and
there's some kind of smooth function
between how those two things happen
yes just last question on this yeah in
the previous night the assumption that
you needed was only that the dot
products are closed not that the
gradients are actually closed
uh right yeah yeah so this is sweeping
under the rug
some details yeah so
yeah there's a lot of
okay
so that's just an empirical
you know
observation of how ntk's are you know
have worse sample complexity than than
neural networks that are not in this mtk
but you know trying to theoretically
characterize what types of problems
can be solved efficiently using
ntk versus cannot be solved efficiently
using ntk is is a kind of wide
area of research currently
and just uh i think the simplest example
of something that cannot be learned
using
these uh you know this empirical ntk
with these random features that i talked
about before
is just a single value neuron right so
if we assume that the x are uniform on
on some unit cube
on the l2 unit cube
and the labels y are given by some relu
neuron with a bias b
so then then the ntk cannot efficiently
approximate those labels y
but neural networks that are not in this
mdk regime or what is called the future
learning regime can
so
by efficiently what i mean is that's the
number of
random features that you're using and
the size of the second layer weights
that you're using
are polynomial in the input dimension
so
work by yehuda and shamir shows that you
need to have either exponentially sized
waves or exponentially many random
features in order to do such a thing
uh but neural networks that are in this
future learning regime can be uh you
know can can solve this problem
so i want to you know so we we've gone
over how we can establish pl
inequalities for neural networks that
are in this ntk regime and i thought it
would be useful to go over
at least one example of how to establish
a pl inequality without relying upon
this
ntk approximation
and this is going to be for linearly
separable data
so let's just remind ourselves of what
the setting is right in order to
establish a pl inequality we need to
construct a matrix v such that we can
bound from below this gradient margin by
some absolute constant
and we'll look at two layer nuts
same setting we had before
but both with what we call leaky
activations okay so leaky in the sense
that's the gradient the derivative of
the activation function is always at
least some constant okay so this is
what's satisfied by leaky value for
instance
and then if you write out what this uh
you know this gradient margin term is
we're given uh an average or you know
sum of these ajs
phi prime of the wjt dot x i
and then y i x i dot v j right and the
task is to construct these v j's such
that this is always some positive
constant
and so we'll consider linearly separable
data that's separable by some margin
gamma
right and we'll let this matrix v
have rows that are given by the scalar
the second layer weights aj
and just the same
vector u in every single row
right so this is a matrix that has
herbinius norm at most one because aj
squared is one over m
norm u squared is at most one so this is
smaller than one
and if we substitute this back into what
we had calculated before right we have
this
aj
y i x i dot v j
we again get we get a j squared to
appear so that's why we get 1 over m
we have a sum of these phi primes times
y i x i dot u
okay so
we have linearly separable data with
some margin gamma so we know that y i x
i dot u is always at least some constant
gamma we also have leaky activations
where phi prime is always at least some
positive constant alpha
okay so no matter what this whole
quantity will always be at least alpha
times gamma
okay then we just substitute this back
in you know into the pl inequality uh
that we've been doing bound it from
below by this gradient margin
and we know that this quantity is always
at least alpha times gamma so we're left
with alpha times gamma times l hat of wt
and the thing to note is that
this is a pl inequality for neural
networks that holds for all times t
and so the inference in particular holds
if we take t to infinity we know that we
can train for as long as we want and
this pl inequality will always hold
what that means is that you know as long
as we can show that this
we can get stationary points
then this empirical risk under the
exponential loss will be small
which is uh which is quite nice because
we aren't making any approximations here
for saying that the gradients are close
to what's going on in initialization the
only kind of key ingredients here are
that this phi prime is always some
constant and that we have linearly
separable data and that's that's a
pretty strong assumption but at least to
give some insight into how we might get
something if we you know don't rely upon
the mtk
and so the idea here was that we always
know what the good features are
to use because we have linearly
separable data
and that phi prime is always at least
some constant you can think about making
this a bit stronger
or you know doing this under some weaker
assumptions on the activation function
for instance if you had like
maybe you can just go and get one over m
sum from j equals one to m
phi prime
w j
t dot x i
right and we have that uh
gamma in front right because if we use
the linearly separable data
and so as long as we can show that this
is you know always some constant then
we're in good shape
right and so the trivial way to do this
is just to look at leaky activations
where five prime is always alpha but you
can also imagine if you have like say
you know that
a constant fraction of the neurons is
always on
then
this would also be fine if phi prime is
not negative
and also the only instance in which this
is uh
equal to to zero say like see if you had
value activations
if i if this is equal to zero everywhere
then there's no gradient update because
then all of the gradients are going to
be equal to zero so you can think about
extending this to other settings
but leaky activations makes things just
a lot cleaner and easy
uh yeah uh
could you remind me if uh if we need the
lower bound to be strictly positive
or can it be
zero
um well you need to be strictly positive
right um because well it's uh trivially
bigger if you just look at the norm is
always non-negative and so you can
always do that lower bound
but you really want to have something
times the loss right because the goal is
to show that the loss goes to zero
and the only thing that we can really
use in non-convex problems is that we
can drive the gradient norm to zero
because that's why we need to have on
the left hand side gradient norm right
hand side something that involves the
loss
losses do you ever have to worry about
like the minimizers being
at an infinity or something like that uh
yeah yeah so so what this what this says
is you know if you have this type of
inequality uh if you can control the
rate at which this goes to zero right
then you can control the rate at which
this goes to the ground
and that's sufficient for understanding
what's going on
right
yeah so
i don't i'm not sure what you mean so
the weights could uh this this doesn't
say that the weights converge to
something uh that's kind of a different
question all it's saying is that
stationary points have small
uh approximate stationary points have
small risk and that's the only thing
that is saying here uh this isn't saying
anything about like what direction wt
converges to
or anything like that that's a
whole host of other problems
is
yeah um that's a good question right so
so l hat of w right is uh
so well l of w
is just one over n
sum from 1 to n of exponential
minus y i
f of x i
wt
and so remember the exponential loss
looks like this and the zero one loss
looks like this
right so if the exponential loss is
small
then the zero one loss is small
so what that would mean is that the
problem you know the
the probability that obviously that y i
will be equal to the sine of f of x i
w
right which is what you want to look at
is if you have a classification problem
you want to say if we classify the
training data correctly then this is
what you want
and the way to guarantee that is to have
the zero one must be small
right because uh
because basically y times f of x
w is less than zero
like y
does not equal
sine of f of x
so that's the kind of
identity
but if this isn't clear i'd be happy to
chat with you adapter
okay
so i'm just going to conclude about
some some generalizations of this pl
inequality and some other kind of high
level ideas about
how we should be thinking about pl
inequalities and neural networks like
not in this ntk regime
right so um the thing that
we started with is was looking at the
exponential loss right of out of you
know many uh
you know this is not the default loss
function that's used for binary
classification and many uh libraries
right the defaults is the cross entropy
loss and a logistic loss
um
and but
we started by just saying you know we
want to minimize some uh convex
surrogate for the zero one loss or so
that when you know the exponential loss
is small it means that the zero one loss
is small
right and we wanna have something convex
because it's zero and and continuous
because the zero one loss is not convex
not continuous so taking gradients of
the zero one loss doesn't make sense
um
but we could also be using the logistic
loss the hinge loss uh sigmoid boss well
this is not convex but in general any
loss function that is uh non-negative
and decreasing
is itself a surrogate for the zero one
loss and maybe this can also help
address the question that you were just
asking right so
because we know that the probability
that
the margin is negative is the same as
the misclassification rate
right and so if we have a
a decreasing l
right this and we apply l to both sides
of this it swaps the inequality
right so this is the same thing as
probability of the loss of the margin is
bigger than loss at zero
and then since l is non-negative we can
use
markov's inequality to bound this from
above by its population risk under l
okay so what this means is that if you
ever have any
decreasing non-negative surrogate for
the zero one loss then itself is a
surrogate uh for you know if you have
any con non-negative and decreasing
function it is going to be a
surrogate for the zero one loss right
and
that's satisfied with the exponential
loss also the logistic loss and the
hinge loss and so on
but the thing to note is that
uh
if we just think about non-negative
decreasing functions as a loss function
for the zero one loss
then
we have a whole family of loss functions
that we could be considering right so if
you take the negative derivative of any
convex and decreasing function
this itself is non-negative and
decreasing
why
well because if it's convex then l prime
prime is positive
so minus l prime prime is negative
so it's going to be decreasing
and we also know that it's non-negative
because
you know
negative l prime is non-negative because
it's a decreasing function
right so all this the main idea is that
if you ever have some convex and
decreasing loss minus l prime is a loss
function is something that you can treat
as a loss function itself
and so why is this helpful
it's if you remember when we were
talking about the exponential laws right
we were talking we we initially when we
established this pl inequality we're
taking the norm of the gradient
bounding it from below by some linear
function of it
and that gives a negative l prime
of the margin
times this gradient margin term
right but now if we're just going to
treat let's suppose you know from like
before we have this gradient margin term
is some constant
but let us just treat minus l prime as a
loss itself
because minus l prime is itself a
circuit for the zero one loss and if
what we care about is the zero one error
in the end then it suffices to show that
the minus l prime loss is small
right i mean this is quite nice then
right because if we have this gradient
margin lower bound
then what we've shown is that's the
gradient norm with respect to l hat
which is the original optimization
problem
this can be bounded from below by a
constant times g hat
at time t
and we we're doing optimization on l so
we know that we can take
this gradient we can drive this gradient
norm down to zero
and if we're driving that gradient norm
down to zero we're driving g hat to zero
and that means that the loss in or minus
l prime is getting small which means
that the loss under the zero one loss is
getting small
right so this allows for you to deal
with any convex decreasing function
just by translating the problem to a
kind of
different loss function that's still
relevant to the problem at hand right
and when we're doing classification what
we really care about is in this
classification error so we can consider
a lot of different surrogates for that
misclassification error to accomplish
the same thing and this is something
that
we we talked about
in a previous work we call a prox cpl
inequality in the sense that there's
some proxy objective function that you
know you're not directly minimizing
but it's still useful for the problem at
hand and this is a very like common
thing that could appear in non-convex
optimization problems is that maybe it's
difficult to say something directly like
a standard pl inequality with respect to
l hat but there might be some other
useful objective function that could
naturally appear when you're analyzing
gradient descent dynamics that still
provides a meaningful guarantee for your
problem
okay i'm just uh gonna be concluding now
uh just to kind of give some
high-level ideas about you know what uh
what what's still going on in neural
network optimization and and how do we
think about optimization beyond this ntk
right and we've been talking about how
it suffices to construct these matrices
v
such that the gradient features using
that that matrix v
classify examples well
right and so
if you don't have linearly separable
data uh
you generally like the general approach
we're trying to be able to understand
this is to consider some type of
structured distribution where the xyis
are iid from some distribution
understand the types of neurons that are
being the types of things that each
neuron is learning right because if you
understand the types of things that each
neuron is learning it gives you some
hold on what's happening with the
gradients in the network at time t
right and then you can think about what
linear functions of the gradient are
able to classify things well and that
gives you a pl inequality
right and this is a subject of a lot of
current work
that's going on
and just to conclude there are a lot of
things in neural network optimization
that i have not been not mentioned today
that are you know active areas of
research and some of the talks uh this
week we'll be talking about
uh one is that uh something that someone
asked before which is that
you know because uh neural networks are
over can be over parameterized there
could be many different weights that
could achieve zero training error
and so what is
the special thing about the weights that
are found by gradient descent they have
special properties that allow for
better generalization or you know do the
architecture just doing great eight
percent on a specific architecture buys
you towards certain solutions that have
different types of properties
you know what do regularizers and you
know these different optimization
parameters that you're using do they
affect the types of things that you
learn
right and you know what how do we choose
the optimization parameters that we can
encourage good behavior in whatever way
that we want
these are all really active areas of
research and i think you'll hear a lot
about it
in this coming week
[Applause]
uh
questions
you mentioned
yeah so you'll want to
yeah so in
like classical analysis of fianna
quality you'll want to have upper bounds
or the gradient orange and two to be
able to make these jelly types
but you can
usually that term is uh
you know that that's something that
helps you with uh
getting the best possible uh analysis
but
it's pretty easy to you know if you have
a small enough step size then
yeah so
i guess so in in the tutorial today i've
just kind of ignored uh how you actually
show that the gradient norm goes to zero
uh when you want to show that the
gradient form goes to zero then you have
to
deal with trying to get upper bounds on
the gradient norm
and that's just something i i didn't
really discuss today but it's uh
i think it's the lower bound is
generally harder
so that was the thing i was focused
uh no so so basically that i'm taking
for granted that we can take this thing
to zero
okay and this and i can maybe talk a bit
more after about how we actually do that
but if you take for granted that great
incentive stationary points
then the only thing that you care about
is bounding having a lower bound on the
gradient norm and something that is a
loss that you want to drive to zero
oh so what do what
yes
okay
last question
um so you said at one point that the pr
framework kind of brings together a lot
of lines of research on like global
optimization
you know if that also includes the mean
sheet limits
or if these are like two totally
unrelated uh uh yeah so i haven't seen
this established in the field takers but
i'm far from an expert in it and
i couldn't really comment on it the one
of the main ideas is that you transform
the problem into a different space where
it is there is convexity and it's not
generally dealing so much with what's
going on with this kind of granular
neural network
so the assumption that
we have such a
code for anytime
is usually what we need to prove yes
yeah that's that's the task of the
statistician is to
the optimization list as to be able to
understand how this type of inequality
works and if you have that then
you get optimization
uh thanks spencer
[Music]
uh